[Music]
my next guest one of the stars of the
hit fx series it's always sunny in
philadelphia let's take a look
[Music]
what the hell is she doing
[Music]
[Music]
i love how free and uninhibited you are
oh yeah
how about i free that big fat snake in
your pants and then inhibit myself all
over it
what
let's hope
[Music]
[Applause]
let's talk about that clip we just saw
what's intriguing to me is you're very
uninhibited in that scene uh and you are
coming onto a man it's very sexy oh yeah
your husband
is uh rob mcelhenny is the co-creator of
the show
and uh he he wrote that he wrote that
yeah that's very strange that he's
that he is making this happen and you
have been
you're playing this woman and he's
making it all happen and then he's
watching it i don't think that anybody
finds that sexual i think he's he knows
that when he writes that i'm gonna make
it look like an [ __ ] so um like i
think when he pictures me doing like a
sexy dance he realizes it's
uh i don't dance i'm all i'm all limbs
and my limbs don't communicate with the
other limbs and i don't you know i'm
good at a lot of things but i'm not like
a sexy dancer what you just said
describes me exactly all limb yeah and
i'm not able to use it in any sexy way
it's just a lie just start to go like
you know like a squid
this is amazing i've never been more in
sync with any woman in my life actually
this is right and i'm wearing this i
can't believe that that felt right i
liked that it did uh
but it's not to be uh-huh no no i am
married with i am married with children
and you yes you look ridiculous please
i again i'm to go with i've changed my
mind okay the point was to look
ridiculous now i think i look incredibly
high okay i'm going with that now yeah
and you can tell by the audience
applause that everyone's with me on that
now
bully don't let him do that to you yeah
it's too late